>>> WE'RE GETTING A QUICK POST
ELECTION LOOK AT HOW HOUSE
REPUBLICANS PLANO USE THEIR
NEW POWER.
CONGRESSWOMAN MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE, FOR EXAMPLE, WANTS TO
AUDIT PAST U.S. MILITARY AID TO
UKRAINE AND SHE WANTS TO STOP
ANY FUTURE U.S. SUPPORT.
>> I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND THE TAXPAYERS OF THIS
COUNTRY DESERVE TO KNOW WHY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND THIS
CONGRESS IS SO INTERESTED IN
FUNDING THE PROTECTION OF
UKRAINE'S BORDER AND NOT THE
PROTECTION OF OUR BORDER.
>> ANOTHER CLEAR PRIORITY IS
INVESTIGATING THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS FAMILY.
THE TOP REPUBLICAN ON THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE TELLS CNN,
QUOTE, THIS NEEDS TO BE CALLED
THE BIDEN INVESTIGATION AND NOT
THE HUNTER BIDEN INVESTIGATION.
>> THERE'S NO PLANS TO SUBPOENA
JOE BIDEN.
THERE ARE PLANS TO SUBPOENA
HUNTER BIDEN.
>> WHY, THEN, WOULD YOU NOT
SUBPOENA JOE BIDEN IF THIS IS
ALL ABOUT JOE BIDEN?
>> WELL, IT'S COMPLICATED TO
SUBPOENA A PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> OUR REPORTERS BACK TO
DISCUSS.
I WANT TO START WITH MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE IN THE SENSE THAT
THEY THINK THAT'S A CLEVER LINE,
YOU KNOW, THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT IS INVOLVED IN A LOT
OF IMPORTANT THINGS, DOMESTIC
POLICY AND FOREIGN POLICY.
THAT IS A PROPAGANDA GIFT TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN, BUT THAT WING OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY DOESN'T
CARE.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
SORT OUT IN CONGRESS, WHAT TO DO
WITH UKRAINE.
THIS HAS HAD SIGNIFICANT
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, YOU SEE THAT
SUPPORT WANING ON THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE IS BECOMING AN ISSUE FOR
THE MAGA WING OF THE PARTY.
CLEARLY THESE PEOPLE HAVE QUITE
A BIT OF INFLUENCE OVER THE NEW
INCOMING REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP,
ASSUMING KEVIN McCARTHY CAN GET
THE SPEAKERSHIP, BUT THAT'S WHAT
THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH NOW.
DO THEY PROVIDE MORE AID IN THE
LAME DUCK SESSION RIGHT NOW
WHERE DEMOCRATS AREN'T IN
CONTROL OF BOTH CHAMBERS.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT THE WHITE
HOUSE WANTS ON THAT FRONT.
>> IS THIS NOT PROOF THAT THE
REPUBLICANS DON'T HAVE A
LEADERSHIP RIGHT NOW IN THE
SENSE THAT EVEN IF YOU BELIEVE
AUDITING OR CUTTING UKRAINE
FUNDING, EVEN IF YOU BELIEVE
THAT'S A PRIORITY, THERE ARE
LEGITIMATE REASONS TO HAVE
OVERSIGHT OF HUNTER BIDEN, WE
WILL SEE IF THEY OVERSTEP BUT
THERE ARE LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS
THERE.
EVEN IF YOU THINK THOSE SHOULD
BE ON YOUR LIST WHERE IS THE
INFLATION AND EDUCATION EVENT
AND THE BORDER EVENT, BIG EVENT
FIRST OUT OF THE BOX.
INSTEAD ANYBODY GETS TO DO WHAT
THEY WANT BECAUSE KEVIN McCARTHY
NEEDS ALL THEIR VOTES SO HE
CAN'T SAY DON'T DO THAT TODAY
SAVE IT UNTIL NEXT WEEK.
>> I THINK AT SOME POINT HE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO DECIDE THAT HE
NEEDS TO LEAD THIS MORE
AFFIRMATIVELY THAN HE IS RIGHT
NOW.
I UNDERSTAND THE MATH IS
COMPLICATED FOR THAT.
TO ME THIS IS A REAL CONTRAST
BETWEEN SENATE REPUBLICANS AND
HOUSE REPUBLICANS AND IT'S
PARTLY BECAUSE SENATE
REPUBLICANS HAVE MORE EXPERIENCE
IN FOREIGN POLICY, HAVE BEEN
AROUND LONGER BECAUSE IT'S
HARDER TO GET ELECTED TO THE
SENATE BECAUSE YOU THINK ABOUT
YOUR ROLE IN THE WORLD MORE THAN
YOU DID DO IN THE HOUSE.
I THINK IT'S BECAUSE PARTLY
SENATORS HAVE TO RUN EVERY SIX
YEARS AND NOT EVERY TWO YEARS.
THIS KIND OF POLITICS, THIS
IS -- THIS IS POLITICS OVER
POLICY.
THIS IS PURE SELF-INTEREST OVER
THINKING ABOUT THE LONG-TERM
GOOD OF THE COUNTRY.
THEY ARE CONFLATING TWO VERY
DIFFERENT EVENTS HERE.
>> IT ALSO DIVIDES THE PARTY.
NOT ALL REPUBLICANS ARE WITH --
IN FACT, I MEAN -- VERY MANY
REPUBLICANS ARE NOT WITH
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE ON THIS
UKRAINE QUESTION.
IF YOU HAD TOLD ME TEN YEARS AGO
THAT IT WAS GOING TO BE
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE ARGUING THAT
WE SHOULD SEND LESS MONEY TO
FIGHT THE WAR AGAINST VLADIMIR
PUTIN I WOULD HAVE TOLD YOU THAT
YOU HAD SEVEN HEADS.
I MEAN, THIS IS A KIND OF -- THE
WORLD IS REALLY UPSIDE DOWN HERE
AND I THINK IT'S -- MAN KNEW IS
RIGHT, THIS MAGA CONSTITUENCY
WILL PRESS FOR IT BUT I THINK IT
CREATES NOR PROBLEMS FOR
REPUBLICANS.
>> THERE IS THE SENSE THAT,
AGAIN, THIS TOWN NEEDS MORE
OVERSIGHT OF JUST ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
THERE IS NO -- WHY SHOULDN'T
CONGRESS LOOK AT HOW U.S.
GOVERNMENT MONEY IS SPENT, WHY
SHOULDN'T CONGRESS LOOK AT
ETHICS, THERE ARE LEGITIMATE
QUESTIONS ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN,
THE BIDEN JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INHERITED AN INVESTIGATION FROM
THE TRUMP JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
IT'S ONGOING.
BUT IF YOU WATCH THAT PRESS
CONFERENCE YESTERDAY THEY
ALREADY HAVE THEIR CONCLUSIONS.
THEY HAVEN'T STARTED THEIR
INVESTIGATION YET BUT THEY
ALREADY KNOW THE END.
THAT'S THE PART WILL IT BE
OVERREACH?
AS OPPOSED TO WE THINK THERE ARE
LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS HERE, WE
HAVE HAD SOME PEOPLE COME IN AND
GIVE US INFORMATION, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO TALK ABOUT IT YOU
BELIEVE CLEE BECAUSE THAT WOULD
BE RECKLESS, WE'RE GOING COULD
CONFIRM AND DO IT.
>> THEY ALREADY HAVE THEIR
CONCLUSIONS.
THEY ARE PROMISING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THIS BIG SMOKING GUN AND
AS WE SAW WITH WHAT HAPPENED
UNDER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
WHEN HE TALKED ABOUT ALL THE
SCANDALS AND CONTROVERSY WITHIN
THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FROM ALL THESE
INVESTIGATIONS AND IT ALL SORT
OF WENT AWAY WITH A WHIMPER
WITHOUT ANY OF THE MAJOR
SCANDALS THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
PROMISING.
SO THE REPUBLICANS COULD BE
SETTING THEMSELVES UP FOR
SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR WHERE
THEY PROMISE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THIS SMOKING GUN NOT ONLY IS
HUNTER BIDEN IMPLICATED BUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS IN ON THIS
MAJOR SCANDAL AND IF THEY DON'T
HAVE THE GOODS, IF THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO PROVE THAT THEN IT'S
GOING TO LOOK LIKE SOMETHING
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
BEING TAKEN FOR A RIDE AND IT'S
GOING TO BE HARD TO BRING PEOPLE
ALONG BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO
ASK WHY SHOULD I CARE ABOUT
HUNTER BIDEN WHEN I HAVE MY OWN
ISSUES, MY OWN FAMILY HAS ISSUES
TO DEAL WITH, NOT THE BIDEN
FAMILY.
>> THERE ARE REPUBLICANS POLLING
IN THE FOCUS GROUPING SAYING
PLEASE DON'T OVERFOCUS ON THIS.
>> THIS IS THE REAL POWER,
THOUGH, OF THE HOUSE MAJORITY,
IT IS NOT PASSING LEGISLATION,
THAT IS GOING TO BE VERY HARD,
EVEN MESSAGING BILLS WILL BE
HARD GIVEN THE NARROW MARGINS
AND THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
30 OR SO FOLKS IN SWING
DISTRICTS, WHO OR SO FOLKS FROM
VERY CONSERVATIVE MEMBERS, THEY
WILL HAVE A HARD TIME AGREEING
ON STUFF, BUT THEY HAVE SUBPOENA
POWER.
IN THE HOUSE YOU HAVE UNILATERAL
SUBPOENA POWER UNLIKE THE SENATE
YOU NEED TO HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON THE COMMITTEES TO
ISSUE SUBPOENAS, IN THE HOUSE
YOU CAN DO IT BY A PARTISAN WAY.
THEY WILL MOVE FORWARD AND JUST
TODAY JIM JORDAN SENDING ALL
LETTERS TRYING TO GET MAYORKAS
TO TESTIFY, SENDING OUT A LETTER
TO RON KLAIN AS WELL SAYING THEY
WANT TO TALK TO A BUNCH OF
OFFICIALS.
>> THEY HAVE SUBPOENA POWER BUT
THEY HAVE 218 SEATS NOW, THERE
ARE FIVE RACES UNCALLED, THE
HIGHEST THEY WILL GET IS 223,
IT'S MORE LIKELY THEY GET TO 220
OR 221.
HAKEEM JEFFRIES SAYS WE WANT TO
TAKE BACK THE MAJORITY.
THE NEXT ELECTION IS A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
IF REPUBLICANS WANT TO PROTECT
THE MAJORITY, AGAIN, LEGITIMATE
OVERSIGHT IS NEEDED IN THIS TOWN
BUT IS THAT WHAT THEY WANT TO DO
OR CAN ANYBODY CONVINCE THEM NOT
TO?
>> I THINK THE POINT YOU MADE
EARLIER IS THE ONE THAT APPLIES
HERE IS THAT IN A WORLD WHERE
KEVIN McCARTHY ONLY HAS THAT
MANY VOTES HE HAS TO LET ALL OF
THESE VARIOUS ELEMENTS OF HIS
CONFERENCE TO A CERTAIN EXTENT
DO WHAT THEY WANT TO DO BECAUSE
OTHERWISE THEY CAN HOLD A LOT
OVER HIS HEAD AND THAT IS GOING
TO POTENTIALLY -- IF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS GO A CERTAIN WAY
AND THERE IS A SENSE OF
OVERREACH WHICH IS OFTEN HARD TO
AVOID IN THESE KINDS OF
SITUATIONS THAT COULD VERY MUCH
ENDANGER HIS MAJORITY FROM AN
ELECTORAL PERSPECTIVE.
>> THE MAJORITY IS BUILT ON
THESE -- ON THESE REPUBLICANS
WHO ARE IN PLUS BIDEN DISTRICTS.
>> RIGHT.
>> THEY MAY NOT BE MODERATE,
SOME ARE KIND OF MODERATE, SOME
ARE CONSERVATIVE BUT GOT ELECTED
TO DISTRICTS THAT BIDEN WON.
THEY KNOW THAT THEY ARE IN GRAVE
DANGER OF LOSING THOSE AFTER TWO
YEARS IF THIS BECOMES A RUN AWAY
TRAIN OF OVERSIGHT
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE BIDEN
FAMILY WITHOUT POLICY --
>> THE MARGINS ARE SO HARD FOR
McCARTHY.
HE HAS THE VOTES TO BECOME
SPEAKER AND THAT IS -- IF HE
DOES HAVE 222 SEATS LIKE HE
EXPECTS THAT MEANS HE CAN ONLY
LOSE FOUR VOTES AND YOU ALREADY
HAVE AT LEAST TWO HARD NO VOTES
ON THE RIGHT, OTHERS IN THE FAR
RIGHT ARE ALSO THREATENING TO
VOTE AGAINST HIM.
HE HAS TO GET THERE -- THERE'S
GOING TO BE A LOT OF MANEUVERING
BEHIND THE SCENES TO GET THERE,
BUT BIG QUESTIONS FOR HIM, TOO.
>> ONE WAY TO GET THERE WAS TO
NOT ASK THESE PEOPLE TO WAIT,
EVEN IF YOU BELIEVE THESE
LEGITIMATE PRIORITIES, HE
CERTAINLY DID NOT SAY PLEASE
DON'T OR IF DID HE THEY DIDN'T